there's five things that you need to
become financially through and I'm about
to give you the five things right now
and we can take notes and if you just
follow and Get These Fine Things it will
completely revolutionize not just your
finances but also your life the first
thing you need
gold a goal a reason why
or you want to be a millionaire you want
to
you want to in property or any business
it's going to get hard one of the things
I've learned in business and in life is
that everything worthwhile getting is
hard it's hard not that I've known much
about this from experience getting a
six-pack I remember when we went to
lockdown in 2020 and I got a personal
trainer and I was trained all the time I
didn't quite get a six-pack well you
know you can kind of see abs and I'm
thinking man this is hard after lockdown
I put a load of weight back on and then
I got fat and you know I also realized I
realized it's hard being fat it's hard
being fat and it's hard being slim it's
hard being broke and it's hard being
rich everything is hard you may as well
choose your heart and get on with it and
if you want to be rich you want to be
successful you need to decide you know
what I'm doing this I'm having this and
you need a goal that will keep you going
where they're going good stuff for you
that might be different to my goal your
goal might be you want to retire your
parents it might be you want to travel
the world it might be that you just want
to not be in a job that you don't like
for the rest of your life so find the
reason the goal and that's the very
first thing you energy financially free
the second thing you need is you need a
Target now the difference between a gold
and a Target is a goal is the why this
is why I want to be successful this is
what I want to do this is what I want to
achieve the target is how much money do
you need to be making on average every
month in passive income through property
to cover your living expenses if I was
mentoring you right now and I got you
some property deals and you were making
an extra thousand pounds a month would
that change your life maybe it would
maybe wouldn't two thousand three
thousand how much would you
would you I can quit work now I can kind
of do what I want now sure I'm not rich
sure I'm not in a position whereby I can
you know buy a big million pound house
and a jet and no but Financial Freedom
is not being rich Financial Freedom is
being free Financial Freedom is having
enough passive income that covers your
life so you don't have to worry about
money so the first thing is goal why do
I need to be successful why do I need to
be rich second thing is what
specifically is Financial Freedom what
is the amount of passive income that I
need to be financially free that's not
the end that's the beginning but that's
the first thing we need to hit so be
really clear on your target the third
thing that you need to be financially
for it is you need a vehicle that's
going to get you there if you're wanting
to go from point A to point B you need
to know are you going to take the bus
are you going to get a car you're going
to learn to drive how are you going to
get from point A to point B you have a
strategy in the same way if you want to
be financially free sure you need a goal
sure you need a Target but you also need
to be really clear on what vehicle is
going to get you there if your target is
2 000 pounds a month if that's all you
need I just need two grand a month and
then I can quit work and I can be
financially free and once I've done that
then I'm going to get rich but firstly
two grand a month how are you gonna do
that what's going to be your vehicle is
it going to be maybe rent to rent maybe
you're gonna rent a couple of apartments
in Birmingham where you live wherever
you live and you're going to rent them
for say 700 pound a month but then
you're going to rent them out for a
hundred pound a night and that's your
strategy I mean damn it if you do that
100 pound a night who's about three
grand a month if you you can find the
property you think I could make three
grand a month on that but it's only on
for rent for 700 and you can get the
correct permission from the landlord
damn you could make even after cost you
can make a thousand pounds do that twice
I should go done if you're enjoying this
video so far don't forget to leave a
like and leave a comment that would
really help me the fourth thing is what
you
need financially free is you need a
support network around you you need a
network trainers success Buddies
to be in the right environment do you
want to try and do something on your own
if you're at home and you're like right
I'm gonna get a rent to rent and you
pick up the phone and you call a
landlord and the landlord says what and
you're like oh and he says no don't we
don't do that kind of thing you know or
rent to rent that's a scam and you're
like oh is it
ooh you're on your own at home and your
spouse you're skeptical what's gonna
happen you're gonna quit whereas if you
are in the right environment
if you're around six seven people that
are winning and you're all together on
the phones
that's what you need to do I mean
environment is stronger than willpower
you can have all the willpower in the
world but but you're gonna get blown
flat and you'll it just loses after a
few weeks potentially like a rubber band
every time you watch a good YouTube
video whoa I'm excited oh back to normal
excited to get back to normal you've got
to be constantly around people you know
the five people that you're around is
how you're going to become we all know
that so I don't know why people continue
to hang around skeptical losers that are
saying what are you doing and I'll just
play it safe new friends new mentors new
rooms new environment the fourth thing
you need is a support network number
five the fifth thing that you need is
you need systems and procedures in place
the ultimate definition of Financial
Freedom is when your passive income
covers your living expenses what does
passive mean passive means it's coming
in without you doing much one thing
ideally how's that going to happen
systems and procedures so the fifth
thing you need is you need systems in
place for instance if you're doing
Airbnb you need to have a channel
manager you need to have key saves
automated emails you need the whole
thing systemized if you're doing deal
sourcing can you systemize deal sourcing
yes you can how by hiring staff training
staff having operations manuals you can
make anything passive when you
understand how to systemize things and
how to hire people so that's Point
number five if you get those five things
you absolutely can become financially
free in 2023 is it going to be easy
nothing's easy but I tell you what it's
worthwhile if you want me to help you I
can help you you want to come down to
the right environment meet me meet my
team find some success buddies come on
down man one pound event come and meet
me come and meet the team I'll leave a
link in the description we're running
programs in Manchester Birmingham Leeds
London come on down let's meet and let's
smash this year
foreign
[Music]